over the past 12 months clark county
school district reports at least
20 students have died by suicide that
number is more than doubled from the
previous year
bianca holdman is live to share more on
what one high school is doing
to educate teens about mental health and
help them bianca
hey good morning sheri so yeah the
district and parents and adults they're
doing more
and putting forth more effort to help
raise awareness around mental health and
matter of fact students here at legacy
high school put their talents together
to create a psa about mental health
awareness
so those teens are in a program called
jobs for nevada's graduate program it's
a very active
program here at legacy high school the
goal is to help teens make better
choices as they navigate through their
high school
journey in years and decide what to do
after the diploma
and here at legacy the program teacher
says that the pandemic and distance
learning had
really taken a toll on her students and
so this psa is to give an encouraging
word
for her the fellow peers of her students
and students created this video telling
others even though
we're all behind mask you're not alone
this psa shows them that
people are stepping out and realizing
and recognizing that there is a problem
um that's the first step to fixing
something
is realizing that there is something
wrong um
i i want this psa to go further than
just
legacy and so there are resources listed
on the ccsd website for students there
is a suicide prevention a lifeline that
you can see there on your screen
1-800-273-talk and then of course
there's a text line we know our teens
like to text so you can also text listen
to 839863 and coming up in the next half
hour we're going to hear from two teens
who are in that psa and in that class
and just the impact they hope the video
makes on other
teens in the valley and of course across
the country reporting live from legacy
high school bianca holman
8 news now